Hello, this is Chris Gould from Geeks on
Tour. I want to show you how to back up
your photos with Picassa. There's simply
nothing more precious on your computer
than your photos, and you should store
them away from your computer somewhere.
Picassa will help you.
I happen to be visiting my mom in South
Florida right now. So, I think I'll make
a entire copy of all my pictures from
2008 so that I can leave them at her
house for
safekeeping. I click on tools, backup
pictures, and notice that a checkbox has
opened up next to all the folders. I
simply check in each box of a folder
that's in
2008. Picasa has tells me that I've
selected,299 pictures, which will take
six CDs or one DVD. I have a DVD burner,
so that's the way I'll do it. But Picasa
is really good about using multiple CDs.
When you fill in the first one, it'll
ask for a second one, etc. All you have
to do now is click burn and put a CD in
the in the drive, of
course. Take those CDs over to your
mom's house. And now you can rest easy
knowing that your pictures are safe.